so somebody has a plan but it's crap we
can't possibly do any worse so I brought
Ryan in because well I've past couple
weeks I've been dealing with the flood
of bad ideas coming out of Sony so you
thought it right yeah who can we counter
these bad ideas with more bad ideas I'll
bring in Ryan yo so what we're gonna do
in a very disorganized non planned
fashion try and come up with our own
better plan for a spider-man universe of
stuff a spider list because that Sony
seems dead cos I think we can start by
just accepting on premise what they
should be doing is introducing these
characters in the spider-man movies
first and then splitting them off sure
can we take it as a given that's what
they should be doing
yeah let's I would call that plan B for
me plan a would be a thing that we
talked about five years ago which was
Sony should sell off their entertainment
division I am an idiot that Fox did at
first we talked about this on the car
going to see guardians of the galaxy vol
1 like the IMAX preview yeah and we were
like why doesn't Sony just give up the
ghost focus on the PlayStation and
whatever other Hardware stuff they have
sell off their entertainment division
get Ghostbusters or spider-man or
whoever and then and then you could this
this wouldn't be an issue that is still
I think that plane 8 should be Plan B
yeah introduced supporting characters
never the in spider-man movies that can
be shared with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in as much or as little as they
want to but give that a little bit of
boost but yeah certainly what it seems
to be they're doing is leaving a
borrowed time just put churning out
properties with the spider-man related
characters that they still have the
movie rights to the lease before the
inevitable collapse yeah so just just to
refresh folk
for what for what is both definitely
happening probably happening and been
announced to happen that probably won't
so what is definitely Havanese we have
venom little coming up this year you
know that's coming out because it's
already been shot in like two months
it's October yes now if I were to lay
down money Morbius is the one that has
the best shot at happening hmm out of
the announced ones because it has a star
attached I wish none of the others do
right and honestly it's the character
who I think supports the solo movie and
starting in a solo movie possibly better
than any other supporting spider-man
character because his story does not
depend on spider-man not at all no and
his and his like the whole the fact that
he's a vampire
in a superhero universe it's very sort
of easily detached very mutable and and
you know you can change that around much
the same way blade was yeah Wow when I
first saw blade I saw with a bunch of
people who had no idea that was a comic
book related movie there is a vampire
hunter thing so I think Morbius can be
approached the exact same way
with potentially the same amount of
success possible because it's not living
or dying based on its connection to the
superhero genre or spider-man in
particular yeah so so the that's the one
that I think it has a decent shot at
happening I think and then there's the
announced ones that I do not think will
ever happen and that's where you find
your Kraven the hunter movie your silver
sable movie or black cat movie they were
gonna be in the same movie now they're
in separate movies and your jackpots
movie look which I and I mention this to
you like jackpot is like a non character
if she was a gimmick character conceived
only to fool fanboys into thinking that
it was Mary Jane well the thing was I
just heard on because Andrew Leyland I'm
catching up on his stuff he talked about
brand new day and you know you mentioned
the early appearances of Jack bottom
like they weren't even being subtle with
hinting that this was Mary Jane they
were laying it on thick like she shows
up she's called jackpot she calls him
tiger she's got the master
it was all bull played into that anyways
so that's that's what their plan is
mm-hmm so I've got a list of characters
now some of these are probably still bad
ideas but they can't possibly be worth
worse than what and let's complete on
these planning any of these ideas could
lead to disastrous movies oh yeah holy
cow yes I'm actually hoping I don't know
man I never have the heart to go see
that fan for stick stuff I I'm not I'm
not sure I want movies coming out that I
can't even bring myself to go watch yeah
so I've got I've got four and then one
that I'm kind of like okay I got three
so okay so I guess I'll start then
here's the one that I actually kind of
like this idea of the best and actually
I remember her having like rumored but
she hasn't been mentioned in a long time
that's it okay so for folks who don't
know silk on paper is a very contrived
and stupid character because she's
basically another student along with
Peter at the same trip where he got
bitten by a radioactive spider she got
bitten by the same spiders she got
powers powers that are slightly
different and honestly that's kind of
dumb here's why I think it could
actually be interesting in work because
we have not actually seen Peter Parker
spider-man origin in the MCU so flashing
back and giving a self's origin with a
actually it wouldn't be like oh god
we're seeing this again we would
actually be seeing it from the first for
the first time but from another
character's perspective so her origin
does not become as inherently
repetitious as it otherwise is because
because it's not giving us something
that we already have seen so that's the
first thing and then I do think in terms
of her I don't want to do it I wouldn't
have them do it the way that they did in
the comics cuz it was wrapped up in some
stupid characters but her big thing for
why was she did not have decent control
for powers at all which included organic
web shooters because obviously Peter s
control that gets his are mechanical so
she
she had powers that she didn't know how
to work she didn't know how to deal with
that she had to come to terms and cope
with before eventually trying to figure
out how to use this stuff for good right
so she's still a little bit repetitious
with how spider-man is but we glossed
over all of Peters or these stumblings
learning how to do this stuff I mean we
see we get a little bit of that with him
like learning how to use the new suit
that Jem but it's very early days of
figuring out how to swing around how to
stick to stuff and even getting bitten
we've never we've never gotten that in
this universe even though we have
spider-man that's true
the only counter to that and this is
admittedly a weak counter but I would
say the reason we didn't get that in
spider-man of homecoming is because
we've gotten it two other times in a
recent memory yes so now you could you
could argue that because we didn't see
it in the MCU it didn't play out that
way for this version of Peter Parker
that is potentially I think then it
might force their hand into addressing
some of these questions but I know you
can still again it's these are classic
sort of origin stories which I think
would be interesting to see so seeing it
from a different characters perspective
perhaps one yeah so actually one of the
ones that was mentioned as a possibility
and they've been talking about this
I do think has potential under the right
guns and that is the silver sable movie
okay now again I think this is a kid if
you detach her the same way you would
Morbius and don't focus so much I'm like
the the spider-man of it all just have a
silver sable in the wild pack which is
she leads a mercenary group of Nazi
hunters you might have to fast-forward
it a little bit to have them chasing
some other kind of you still have
neo-nazis and fascism yeah well you know
you could have them do you could have
them be subcontracted to hunt down Hydra
since shield is now unofficial because
that that you could or some version of
that if there becomes a rights issue
between the Marvel Universe's
well it could be anything it could be an
established comic book thing or it could
be something completely different but
you essentially had and I would the
approach I would have it would be
something very much in the realm of a
sort of less less big garish superhero
stuff and more grounded like a Bourne
Identity zero dark thirty type of like
war type of like a like a mercenary
squad that happens to be led by this
woman with silver hair and everything
like that and kind of a focus on that
and then the pin drop that could be at
the very end is either you you see this
like in the post-credits stinger of a
variant or you setup for the sequel is
there tasked with going after a venom
but you don't make that the focus of the
first movie you don't even play it into
it it would either be a post-credits
thing or something for the sequel kind
of the way I guess you have the matter
thing with what and that Shyamalan is
done with unbreakable was blade split
and then the new one which is glass
thank you how you didn't even know that
they were sure universe until until the
very end of like the second one so okay
I think something like that could be
doing don't make it seem like it's
anything it's just a completely separate
movie until the very end
oh by the way here's your next target it
says Eddie Brock guy who's got these
weird powers I I like that ending a lot
what would the one the one question I
would have in this wouldn't that this
wouldn't stop Sony but this is my sort
of perspective from an audience member
when you mentioned the tone and sort of
you know Jason Bourne zero dark thirty
my immediate thought is are we stepping
on black widows solo movie tellers we
don't know what her solo movies gonna be
like that's true that's true
it could be more mission impossible like
or something like that a little bit more
a little bit grander scale a little bit
more spectacle but I like that singer I
thought the idea of putting her and
black cat together was a stupid thing
like forcing two very unrelated
characters just because they're women at
a time when I was like wait what Wonder
Woman was exposed so did women all these
movies and the fact that they both had
I'm naturally white hair yeah there was
like there was never a reason for those
two to be together so it just felt weird
but I think individually silver sable
you could tell an interesting story
about a mercenary Nazi hunter war fast
or a bet - whatever you want to be but I
think there is merit to some kind of
story with her okay
with black cap I think you're just doing
Catwoman yeah pretty much I mean that's
kind of all she ever I mean I like black
cat I do like a black cat a lot but
she's really just just the marble
governor of Catwoman right and without
spider-man she's less yes yeah black cat
without spider-man is not anything
interesting yeah okay so next up this
one all right this one's a little bit
this one's weird see if we can stick
with me with this Clone Saga oh god no I
seriously took a look at that and then I
just thought no I thought I was trying
to figure out if there was a way to do
that and I couldn't I yeah I don't think
there's any way to do it where it's not
a total cluster word I'd have to bleed
so Betty Brant okay so how familiar are
you with the sort of special thing that
was done with Alec Ross called Marvel's
alright love it I've read it okay on it
my concept would be it to sort of take
that style of storytelling doing it
through the eyes of Betty Brant because
the whole if for anyone who hasn't read
marbles it's just to look at the birth
of the Marvel Universe and some of the
early major events in it from the
perspective of this photographer yeah a
man on the street type of way yeah and
so you get you get a view of events that
you haven't gotten before and I would go
for something similar with Betty Brant
because normally Betty Brant is just Jay
jonah Jameson's assistant I think you'd
have to have her actually be a reporter
but you have her at the bugle which
means we can bring Jonah in because I
think we all miss him I don't know how
you replace JK Simmons but somebody
somebody's chomping at the bit to give
it a go yeah so he'll give to Bruce
Campbell
but you you then have her you have
getting her perspective on well
initially of course spider-man by then
venom willow happened and other things
along those lines and hurt and you
getting that from the ground level
reporter view of these events going on
with this character who has no event who
has ties to the Daily Bugle which you
could eventually tie back to spider-man
if you want to be smart and actually
have these things connect in some way at
some point but she doesn't have to start
in the in the spider-man mmm-hmm things
now the the trick is then finding a main
thrust of a plot that isn't just
uncovering conspiracy BS because that's
dull and boring and played out and I
haven't got that far but like has a core
concept and an angle at it that's where
that's what I'm thinking I like the idea
I like the idea of fleshing that
character out that's if she doesn't have
the name recognition people at least
know for in proximity to the characters
that we already know and love yeah and
getting that type of man on the street
or woman on the street like looking up
at the sky as these miraculous things
are going on above you I like that idea
and sort of playing that out as a as an
investigative reporter journalist
looking into these you know fantastical
and amazing things I think that's a cool
idea
well yeah um for my next one actually
another tangental spider-man related
character would be the Prowler you can
actually combine these then so I know
the thing about this one is I think they
could take it two distinct directions
because in spider-man homecoming they
sort of seeded the idea that Donald
blubbers character could be the Prowler
because the name of that character in
the movie is one of the aliases used by
the Prowler in the comics yes so that
could be the connection he actually
mentions having a nephew that was run
there like that's an easter egg from
Miles Morales so you couldn't very much
do you know you could say cast donald
glover again having basically a dance
that's what i would yeah makes me spin
that character off into his own thing
and then you still had that connection
of him sort of being in the Marvel
Universe even if he never sees
spider-man again
and the end of our other aesthetic
characters alternatively if you didn't
want that baggage you could just recast
rename and just do a completely
different Prowler movie but I think
that's a very interesting character
another black superhero after the
explosion Black Panther there's
certainly a market and they thirst for
that type of representation I mean I
think I think if you were to do that and
not use Donald Glover that you you
really missed the trick on that because
I mean it was there anyone who said who
saw so who didn't say he was the one of
the best things about it he absolutely
wasn't and and my only concern about
that was looking at the way he played
the character in homecoming doesn't
strike me as leading man in a superhero
type of movie but Donald weather has
that kind of weird charismatic x-factor
about him that I think he could do a
very different spin on it and still sell
it yeah yeah my preferred version would
be absolutely have him play the part
I've cast him in anything I think he
would have been a better console oh okay
they couldn't hurt awful of that the
movie was just bland yeah okay so I got
all right I gotta jump around now this
next one I tried to avoid pulling in
anything that I know is gonna be in into
the spider-verse
okay because I'm kind of gained for that
becoming its own independent thing up
because like we know that that is gonna
have spider-man you are it's gonna
spider-gwen actually future video let us
know if you want us to talk about this
but I would like to talk about possible
other avenues for them to do animated
features in the Marvel Universe over
there I'd be down because we know that
they're doing that into the spiders
they've done big hero 6 in the past but
yeah also really good so if you want to
hear more about those I've got some
ideas ooh
I might put that on the docket
regardless of what the responses so that
would be bastard
so I you know trying trying to avoid
stepping on toes and I don't I couldn't
find confirmation that this character is
into the spy reverse he might be though
even if he is I don't care I wanted to
get his own movie that's spider-man 29
into 2099 I left this one up because I
knew you a victim oh of course you did I
love Miguel O'Hara
I love makes so much so I mean that the
name says it all it is it is at this
point no longer 100 years in the future
80 years oh god we're old from when it
was published it was over a hundred
years into the future
you know heroes aren't really around
anymore and this genetic engineer
through an accident ends up with powers
that grant him the same final skills as
spider-man the way that works is a
little bit different like he couldn't
Stu walls but it's because he's got
these razor-sharp retractable talons
that he could actually slash a guy's
throat with uh-huh so was the nineties
they could only go so far from you know
better yeah it was a good property a
little bit but I I love I love this
character I love his look
I love his feet because he he manages to
embody a certain amount of the hapless
nests that Peter Parker often has and
he's able to have the the witty banter
under the guise of oh my god I have to
say something new so they don't know
that I'm as terrified as I am but he is
still a very distinct entity he doesn't
feel like just Peter in the future but
he evokes a lot of what is great about
spider-man and me you basically just
drop spider-man into the world of Blade
Runner that is spider-man 2099 and I
want to see that movie
you know that's good you were you were
wise nothing not the drying take that
all right then my final one that I came
up with and I was very happy when I sold
on this one back wooden Sony was plowing
ahead with amazing spider-man amazing
spider-man 2 it looked like they were
going full steam for a sinister six
movie we both thought that was terrible
now not only did we think we know
because you jus gotta let the daredevil
TV show to work on that anywho so one of
the reasons that why I didn't like the
idea was I didn't want them squandering
and wasting all of these characters
associated with the sinister six that I
loved characters like Doctor Octopus
Mysterio vulture now that they've used
Kraven the hunter and the Lisbon I want
all of these characters to still be
available as spider-man villains in the
main spider-man saga of movies that
they're doing without Holland however
what I would be happy with is if they
went with the c-list sinister six
also known as the deadly foes of
spider-man or sometimes these superior
foes of spider-man
this is characters like boomerang the
beetle speed demon who changed his name
because he was originally the wizard and
other Mort villains like that so you
take these as basically a gang of
criminal of super criminals who get
together the thing is they're not
fighting major big-time superheroes like
spider-man or even daredevil or other
things like that they are not saving the
world like the Suicide Squad from a
giant blue laser is flying up in the sky
these guys are just they use their
powers just to rob people and steal
things and they are bastards through and
through and their major problem is they
get caught up in a gang war between guys
like hammerhead and Silvio Silvermane
and war
that's thing even though you know you've
got a guy who's like whose superpower
he's got like a beetle super a guy who
can throw boomerangs or something these
guys are still terrified of tombstone or
hammerhead coming after them and they're
just caught up as as pawns in this game
or of things like that I'm borrowing
very heavily from the side of the
superior foes of spider-man and you know
what else you you could you can actually
have like extended hai sequences for
people with superpowers with like we got
that a little bit with ant-man but only
one guy like imagine the whole heist
crew right I'll have the only have these
weird ass
yeah yeah and like yeah basically
everything kind of goes around and like
going back to the comics if every one of
like the first couple of issues open
with a splash page of one of them
getting terrorized but but beating up my
spider-man or shot at by the Punisher
and always began with the same opening
caption was this freaking dad right so
something like that that's under here is
basically a it now like suicide to avoid
a super-powered gangster movie or a
super-powered crux movie on when you
just really do have these see of d-list
guys who are just trying to rob money to
bail the friends out of jail or
something like that or you know like
basically just like steal stealing
puppies from the shelter or something
just to spite a little kid and teach her
a lesson that you can't trust anybody
but things like this awfully well yeah
and then like yeah their problem isn't
superheroes the problem is the legit
gangsters like the owl will be coming
for them things like that so I think I
like that a lot
it would be ok so the super criminal
version as directed by Guy Ritchie from
like lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
slash snatch that era Guy Ritchie
putting a spin on the super villains oh
god yeah that's what I'm thinking wow I
love that although I do have death did
you realize they've actually integrated
the wizard into the MCU alright how
season 2 it Jessica Jones oh okay we
have we have the wizard he's even called
the wizard okay well you either you
either like rename and do the speed
demon thing or you find another you
no shortage of mortville you can find
other other Lister's i just in the
series that I mentioned the Shocker is
one of the regular guys and they've
already used him to of him actually in
spider-man homecoming yeah although that
could be that could be your one actually
yeah get booking goodbye and come back
and play the same character yeah never
liked it now look I just have that B or
one bit of crossover interconnectedness
so the last thing I've got this is sort
of the one that I had a question mark
after just because I didn't thinking of
it through because I think you'd have to
change which character this is kind of
versus what what he is in the comics and
that I still think a much better idea if
they were gonna do venom as they should
have done agent venom mmm and so again
in case folks don't know so agent venom
is the military attempting to weaponize
a symbiote and and use it for military
application but the guy who it's
attached to you
he's a soldier he's trained he's
disciplined and he is battling this
thing to thin nail in his own head
basically non-stop yeah when he's when
he's in control
he is precise he is almost unstoppable
but when he's not 100% in control it
gets real messy real quick and I don't
just mean in terms of violence like 80
if he's supposed to go in and go
stealthy and suddenly the simply it's
like no brains because like well so much
for stealthy now in the comics this is
Flash Thompson right and the comics that
works because Flash Thompson is a jock
but it works for the Joe Manganiello
spider-man 1 yes the the big bruiser
jock who terrorizes a nerd in high
school exactly the problem is we have
Flash Thompson introduced in this matter
man homecoming is it completely
different now I actually really like the
changes of you did the Flash Thompson
because he's a 21st century bully
wait as opposed to that you know the big
job which is such a tired stereotype and
I don't think is even accurate to the
high-school experience anymore
but actually not like a science Academy
in high school yeah but that does mean
it makes it I do think it's it's too far
to believe that that version of Flash
Thompson whatever enroll in the military
no so we need to don't tell us maybe but
now yeah yeah but not yeah yeah
he never do fieldwork right so they
never equipped him with this stuff so we
we would need they'd either need to find
or invent another character to actually
latch this on to and I would say you
could even spin this off right from
venom itself if because I the
implication that I'm getting is that
these silly 'its are I'm either
controlled or create or whatever they're
having by a private company so if the
government confiscates them at the end
of venom then they're gonna try and do
something with them sure so you can you
can spin it off from that or if we
actually get other stuff going off the
ground silver sable and her crew could
be saddled with agent venom at trying to
track down Eddie Brock sure so they've
gotten they've got this loose cannon on
their team at the same time they're
trying to nab the original yeah yeah but
that but like is that that one had a bad
a bit of a question mark after it yeah I
think I mean a lot of it will depend on
what happens with men on them yeah
whether it's accepted or not I I mean
who who knows maybe maybe that movie
will surprise us and be and be fun and
entertaining and maybe it'll just you
know waft away like a turd in the wind I
don't think I'm going to see it in the
theater so I probably am because I'm too
morbidly curious yeah like a it's not to
the point like that this time last year
I was putting my foot down and saying
I'm not spending money on on some of
these things anymore I I think I've
given up my dignity it's having a
newborn child is the perfect excuse to
not see these movies that I wrote
because I ended up seeing GI Joe
raishin in the theater because I've
literally had no excuse about it but I
mean I'm sorry
ya know so though that's all random
spitballing for for what to do with
spider-man and expand it out and do a
universe that nobody asked for but hey
they're determined to do it anyways sure
so what are your folks tops on any of
the ideas we pitched what are yours
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a bunch of buttons to push and links to
hit check those out if you feel like it
I've got a patreon that's kind of the
big one but yeah you know whatever so
thanks so much for tuning in Thank You
Ryan for showing up
I mean drinking my booze cool
just remember folks you are the council
I just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]